as part of our work in progress series
with LinkedIn we're taking a look at why
the professional networking site says
fall is the best time to find a job
I think it's fall right now a new survey
can be committed by LinkedIn found
October has the highest number of job
openings on its website eighty-nine
percent eighty nine percent of hiring
managers fill those spots in less than
four weeks with a national unemployment
rate at 50-year low now could be the
perfect time to land your dream job
LinkedIn editor-in-chief that's Dan Roth
is here with some tips on how to do that
you actually said that this is a good
time to be looking for a job and what's
the best day to apply for a job Mondays
more job listings tomorrow exactly why
why that I think a lot of hiring
managers spend the week getting their
job descriptions ready Monday start the
week off put your job description up and
wait for the resumes that are coming in
and you found that it's I mean it's
really good to be first in line it is it
is helpful to be first in line but it is
not the end-all be-all the real key is
making sure that you are out there with
your profile that you're sharing you're
talking about what you're an expert in
right got your skills listed that you
are networking with people you want to
make sure that you were actually out in
the market so that if you're very
passive so if you're a hiring manager
huh they'll look for passive job
candidates and people who are just a bit
don't you find that if you're one of the
first 25 applicants to apply to a job
you're three times more likely to land
it I think that firl the you know you
shows a lot of excitement if you're a
hiring manager these people like they
clearly want to get in the door and you
and also if you're hiring you're like I
got to fill this by the time you list a
job you want that job filled right away
the by the time you listed you're like I
got it you wish you had done it once
before yeah so that you want to fill it
yeah didn't want to focus on your skills
in a resume that's obvious they
demonstrate those skills to the extent
possible how do you how do you dammit
how you break through yeah on a piece of
paper to demonstrate skills that are
happening in an office problem well if
you were just relying on a piece of
paper you're doing it wrong the most
important thing is be out there you want
to share your expertise constantly talk
about what you know ask questions share
stories that are interesting to you you
want to demonstrate you know your your
profile is just an image of where you've
worked it's just like your skeleton but
you want to put meat on that you want to
explain how you think what if you're a
if you're hiring you want to make sure
you're hiring someone who doesn't just
have all the has done exactly but that
they think right that they're smart
asking the right questions I always say
Dan you've got to figure out a way to
get a face-to-face interview because I
used to say if I could just get my face
in the door that's right I will do
whatever it takes to knock it out of the
park but you you also said that you
don't think companies are doing enough
to attract people yeah a lot of people a
lot of companies are still trapped in
this kind of post recession mindset
where they think they are gonna hire
exactly the right person there look have
a name unicorn look at the unicorns you
got to stop looking for unicorns you
know they still look at big gaps in
employment and say this person I don't
know what they were doing or someone had
a lot of jobs we don't want job hoppers
but in a tight labor market we're at a
50-year low and an unemployment yeah you
have to be thinking much more
expansively about who can fill these
kind of jobs be willing to take risks be
willing to train people you want to get
an unorthodox candidates and the smart
companies are starting to do that if
you're one of those means if so many
people now applying they have to your
apply online yeah so you it's your
resume as upfront and Gale talks about
trying to get that interview but it's
hard to get yeah how do you stand out in
that well a couple things you want to
make sure that your skills are listed a
lot of companies now they're not just
looking at where you've worked they're
looking at do you have the right skills
for this job so take skill assessments
take courses make sure you're listing
those on your profile but also really
you have to right share talk shoot
videos you have to be out there shooting
video yeah you want to be you know on
your phone saying oh I'm at a conference
here I'm at this conference and I met
these people and here's what I know
think companies are getting more
creative absolutely cut we know the
recruiters are being asked to take
creative writing classes to write better
job descriptions to attract people but
also you just have to be able to show
that you know how to talk the biggest
job the biggest skill that's in demand
for companies right now is communication
skills yeah you can show that you can
communicate you have a better chance
bartenders are doing okay yeah I don't
mean by they don't mean communications
by emoji is the old-fashioned thing
whatever works yeah Dan thank you very
much thanks Rishi eight